foreign
so thanks christos it's uh very nice to
be
back here in berkeley
today i'm going to talk about some work
we've been doing um
over a number of years uh i guess it
started for me almost as a bit of a
hobby back in 2000 as i'll explain
sort of a project on the side but it's
um
it sort of involved a number of people
along the way and more recently
biologists people like bill martin
in dusseldorf who work
very actively in this area of origin of
life
most of the work today will be work with
vimhoudaike postdoc
josh a student with us in christchurch
alcana marcel who's in the statistics
department here at berkeley and a little
bit of recent work with stuart kaufman
so of course the origin of life is a
very uh
uh difficult question and and many
people have um thought about it all the
way back to
charles darwin who speculated about the
warm little pond idea he had
and in a talk such as this there's no
time really to go into all the many and
varied theories of how life began
let me just say in summary that there
are many ideas some are very specific
like the martin and russell idea of the
hydrothermal vents and the way
biochemistry got going
this general i suppose there's a fair
amount of agreement that somehow rna
played a dominant role early on in life
rather than for dna
but there's a lot of debate about
what you might call a chicken
or egg problem was it
genetics first or metabolism first or
some combination of both
i think it's fair to say though that
whatever early life was like it was a
lot simpler than it is today if you look
inside for example
a cell of e coli you'll see
maybe 2 000 or more reactions
and a similar number of molecules
and they're all highly organized in the
sense that
all those reactions the reactants
are either
available in the environment or they're
produced by other reactions and every
reaction is catalyzed by some enzyme or
cofactor because it all has to work in
some sort of synchronized fashion
so there are many problems
concerning the origin of life but one in
particular
seems to be the following
that it would seem that
an early step would would be
that seems to be required is that you
have some the emergence of some
self-sustaining auto catalytic network
of reactions that is a set of reactions
that sustained either by what's here in
the environment or what's produced by
those reactions
and auto catalytic in the sense that
each reaction is catalyzed also by
something produced by the system
i'll talk about this
later this particular example
so why is catalysis important well you
all know probably that it speeds up
reactions enormously by many orders of
magnitude so that will stop reactants
diffusing before they've had time to
react but and you see this in this graph
here this these are uncatalyzed reaction
rates and these are the catalyzed rates
but what's more striking or equally
striking
is that the
variance or the variation
in the reaction times is much narrower
for catalyzed reactions than it is for
uncatalyzed so you have the opportunity
of synchronizing processes
so the rates are not only faster but
they're more tightly coordinated
so there's a certain amount of
formalizing in this talk and i'm just
going to start here i might write some
things on this whiteboard i take it i
must never write on here must i
okay
so for the purposes of this talk i'm
going to say a catalytic reaction system
is a quadruple it's a set of molecule
types a set of reactions a set of
catalysis pairs and a food set
so the reactions are just
some molecules come out and some
molecules
some molecules come into the reaction
and some molecules go out
so the things coming in we call
reactants the things coming out we call
products
and i'll denote them in this way
row and pi
the catalysis is just a set of ordered
pairs a molecule catalyzes a reaction
we'll regard that as an ordered pair
x r
okay so here's here's a reaction two
molecules produce two products
the food set will simply be
a subset of the molecule types
okay so i'm just going to write this up
first so we remember this the basic
setup of a crs we've got x
a set of reactions we start with
a catalysis pattern and a set of food
molecules
yeah so food is just what's available in
the environment in the context of early
life this would be what molecules were
available early on
uh okay so that's a sort of an abstract
view perhaps a more pictorial view is to
think of this as a directed bipartite
graph you have a two sorts of
vertices the molecules which we've
indicated here with
solid dots and the reactions which we've
indicated with little square white
squares
and you have two types of arrows you
have
for example here
this food molecule comes in to this
reaction and goes out but you also have
these catalysis arcs so the arrows
denote
one type of arrow denotes
reactants coming in and products going
out the other dashed arrows
are representing catalysis
and the food molecules i'll indicate in
green so i suppose really i could almost
say we've got three types of vertices
we've got molecules and some of those
happen to be food and some not
and we've got
the reactions
okay so this these are two examples of
catalytic reaction systems
so here's a very simple model of such a
system somewhat abstract model
it's called the
call it the binary polymer model we
imagine sets of molecules represented by
strings over an alphabet
this could be ac gt or whatever but
let's think of binary strings just to
keep things simple okay going to
consider
binary polymers up to length in and the
food molecules will just be the short
things perhaps monomers and dimers
so t here
might typically be perhaps two
so the sorts of reactions we're
interested in are
what are called
ligation and cleavage reactions ligation
reaction we just take two
strings and we concatenate them a
ligation we take a string and we just
cut it somewhere and separate them
so this is a subset of all of the
reactions
in this binary polymer model
and these would be some of the reactions
here's the the food set or some of the
idea
some of the molecules down here
and we're going to be interested in the
following
model
we're going to suppose that this
catalysis i've drawn here is just
randomly assigned i look at each
molecule i look at each reaction i toss
a biased coin with probability p i put a
catalyzation arc in there that is an
extremely naive and simple model i'm
going to call it the vanilla model
because there's all sorts of extensions
of that perhaps the probability of
catalysis depends
on the length of this molecule perhaps
it depends on how well x somehow
fits the corresponding
reactants and product but for now
whenever i talk about the vanilla model
i'm thinking of this very most simple
situation
so why did i get interested in this well
there was this early claim by kaufman
that somehow
in this binary polymer model if you fix
p
and you let n get large enough then
you will find these
self-sustaining auto catalytic systems
inevitably arising arising with
certainty
a little bit like what happens with
random graphs as you add edges
eventually it becomes
connected with high probability of
course eventually it becomes just a
clique if you add enough
um
and
so i wanted to sort of
think about this a little more
mathematically
kaufman proved a theorem here and that
theorem is
absolutely correct but the reason i got
interested it was this paper by listen
who pointed out well
what kaufman asserts is true but if you
keep
the probability of catalyzation constant
and you increase in
it requires
the average number of
reactions that each molecule catalyzes
has to grow exponentially with the
sequence length and that's by
biochemically totally unreasonable so
each molecule would have to catalyze a
huge number of reactions
uh there's other criticisms
which should be made and i want to
address all of these in my talk but in
order to make some progress on this
first question what i wanted to
to think about with uh
lists some criticism is um
well that's true but what if you allow p
not to
be constant allow it to perhaps decrease
with
within
what would happen in that case
okay so
we're going to use some
fairly simple mathematics to try and
look at the how this binary polymer
model behaves what level of catalysis is
really needed in order to
ensure
self-sustaining auto catalytic system
but we need to formalize some notions
first and i think you'll appreciate why
because i've been saying things like
a self-sustaining auto catalytic system
what does that really mean when we
formalize it we'll see that there are
subtle differences in what that could
mean and they have a big impact on what
the answer would be
so we need some
definitions
so given any subset r my initial set of
reactions now this is true what i'm
saying in these next few slides is for
any catalytic reaction system not just
the binary polymer model okay so given
any subset of reactions we'll say the
closure of the food set is all of the
molecules that i can get by just
applying the reactions in that subset
repeatedly
all the molecules i can build up
closure of f
exactly and that's whether they are
catalyzed or not
ignoring catalysis
so formally it's a unique minimal subset
of x it contains
f and that satisfies this this property
of course the closure of f is easy to
compute
polynomial time in the size of q
whenever i say polynomial time here i
don't mean anything to do with n talking
about the size of the input
second definition
f generated
we say that a subset of reactions is f
generated if the closure contains every
reactant of every reaction in r
so
this
system here
i haven't shown any catalysis because
that's not relevant at this point
this is f generated i use these and i
generate that and then these two
generate that and you see i can build it
all up
it's f generated
if generated implies of course that each
reactant of any reaction in r is either
in if or is a product of some other
reaction in r
now is the converse true
question
well it turns out not to be i mean
here's an example where this is true but
this is not if generated
i couldn't start with f and just using
my reactions
generate this
once this is going it's going to keep
going but it's never going to start
okay this this is able to start and keep
going
but
this is not so this is not if generated
so important distinction between f
generated and not
so now we come to the main idea which is
what we call a wrath
it's a subset of reactions that
satisfies these two three properties
first of all it should be non-empty
secondly every reaction in that set
should be catalyzed either by the
product of some other reaction or
perhaps by an element of the food set
and it needs to be if generated
so here is um
crs is that a ref an raf does it satisfy
those properties certainly not empty
but
you see only this part of it is a an raf
this reaction for example is not
catalyzed at all
let's look at the earlier example i
showed you
uh can we see any rafs in there
uh well i can see
one just here these are the food sets
and that catalyzes that so
that's one what about over here well
this is
you can check
that's an raf so too is that and if i
put them together then they will be also
that's also an raf
uh is that the biggest raf well no it's
not because now that this is established
i can add that in this reaction r5 by
itself is not an raf but
i can add it to this set there and get
an raf okay so that would be
the
maximal raf
so at this point you ask questions like
hm is there always a unique maximal raf
and you see actually yes there is
because well before i come to that let
me just say that this notion has an
equivalent definition that's perhaps
easier to pass
a subset is an raf it's non-empty and
each reaction are in that set
all of the reactants and at least one
catalyst of r are present in the closure
of f under earth it's another way of
thinking about it
so this is an raf here
it's if generated and every reaction is
catalyzed
but it's okay if i like need a huge
number of reactions to happen before the
first catalyst is produced and then it
goes back
that is a very good question uh
absolutely it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter in fact you may be interested to
know that computing the smallest number
of reactions that has to happen
uncatalyzed in a given wrath
um in you know
is an np hard problem to calculate
so
some of the reactions require a catalyst
and some don't
all of the reactions required to be
catalyzed but you see here what happens
is this reaction this first one has to
start without catalysis eventually the
catalyst is produced yeah i'll come to
that distinction in a little bit in two
more slides i want to just
state a couple of fairly obvious
but very useful properties of re first
of all the union of two ras is an raf as
we saw before that's fairly easy to
verify
um
it follows that any catalytic reaction
system has a unique maximal raf namely
the union of all of the rafs it contains
secondly there's a simple algorithm to
determine whether or not q has an raf
and if so to compute the maximum one
i'm sure the computer scientists among
you will by the time i get to the slide
after the next will have figured this
algorithm out but let me just
say why it's useful it's useful because
it means you can take very large systems
and very quickly find the max ref or see
if there is a ref in there at all
so now i come
to this
some of the questions that have been
very pertinent about catalysis we've got
the notion of a wrath
a stronger notion would be this notion
that hang on we need to catalyze
everything before it will happen we call
this a constructively auto catalytic
gift generated
process a weaker notion than a raf is
this where every reaction has
is
its reactants
and at least one catalyst is a product
of another reaction what's in the food
set this we call a pseudo wrap
this is not a wrap
again this could never start
whereas this could start and why do i
say that
i say that because
if the reactants aren't there the
reaction can't happen
but if the catalyst is not there and the
reactants are the reaction can happen
but at a low rate
so i think this is somehow a good
compromise
eventually this will get going and then
it's going fast somehow
we'll see there's good mathematical
reasons too why rafs are more
interesting in some sense than
this stronger notion of caf i don't
think i think the
more interesting one is the constructed
catalytic
rather than the raf because if the raf
inevitably starts
then it can't actually be relevant for
evolution
you need something which has a low
probability of starting unless
uh by some low probability reaction the
catalyst has arisen there
so that
it can actually be
a rare
event which is
um transmitting information if
something's inevitable
then it can't be relevant for evolution
i thought you were you're agreeing with
them you're saying that the raf is is
more interesting no i'm saying that
the constructively water catalytic one
is more interesting than the raf that's
one that starts easier yeah
that's one that starts rapidly no you
need to have
uh the
all the catalysts there in the first
place for the constructive
yeah i guess we're sort of thinking that
you know early on there wasn't much and
we needed somehow to work with minimal
things we didn't want the luxury of
everything being sitting there waiting
to catalyze i i take your point and
perhaps we can discuss that afterwards
so the raf algorithm
is very simple of course you just
start with your original set of
reactions and you just construct a
nested decreasing sequence
at each step all you do is you throw out
all the reactants that
all the reactions rather that fail to
have all their reactants
and any
catalyst in the closure of what you've
constructed so far
and if at the end you'll i mean this is
a decreasing
sequence of subsets of a finite set so
it must terminate you'll either end up
with the empty set in which case there
is no ref in the system or it will be
the max ref
actually you can make this algorithm a
little more efficient
by iterating this step
by computing the max pseudo ref because
max pseudo-ref is really can be solved
in linear time by
algorithms for
horn satisfiability it's a nice way of
encoding this problem
okay um
back to the kaufman story
we want to look at the
full binary polymer model so that's all
binary sequences of lengths up to n over
two letters
the number of molecules is
one plus two plus two squared up to 2 to
the n which is 2 to the n plus 1 more or
less and this is the number of reactions
the reactions are all cleavage and
migration
reactions
so i'm just going to write some of these
down
and mu is the average number of
reactions catalyzed by any given
molecule so if in the case where you
have
probability molecule x catalyses
reaction r this will just be
p times r zero
so what we're interested in is what's
the probability that
the set we start with contains within it
an raf pm
i'm sorry can you remind me
p is just a fixed constant for the
moment
the probability that a given molecule
catalyzes any other given
so is the probability that the more is
the catalyst yes exactly yeah so this
would be the expected number of
reactions that a given molecule
catalyses in the vanilla model okay so
kaufman as i said
established that if p is constant that
is doesn't depend on n
that pn goes to 1 as n goes to infinity
and
in a way though the result is a little
unsatisfactory for two reasons first of
all it requires you see
this is growing this rate so if p is
constant mu is growing at that
exponential rate
but also the ref you end up with is all
reactions
so it's sort of like what
the irish's esmere sometimes calls the
tar or whatever you just get everything
and that's sort of not really
interesting
so what if mu were to grow more slowly
and this is where i got interested in
this and i established these first two
results
that if
mu is less than
130 to the minus one
the probability there was a ref would go
to zero if it was bigger than quadratic
uh well i should say bigger than c n
squared where c is more than
log two to the base e then it would go
to one as n goes to infinity
and the reviewer of
one of the reviewers of that paper david
sankoff
said well this is all fine but you need
to make a conjecture about what the
real rate is is it is it um
is it constant is it quadratic and i
just had no idea really i said i
conjectured it subquadratic
okay so then um i had
didn't know how really to make much
progress but i was fortunate to have a
postdoc
vimhordik come to new zealand for a
little while and he said well let's try
simulating and i said no we want to
prove a theorem he said well let's see
anyway
okay and so what he found was the um
this is mu and these are different
values of n8 10 12 and so forth and you
see there's a sort of sharp transition
that occurs this is the probability that
there is a wrath within the system
and you see it sort of drifting to the
right and what does that trend look like
if i sort of look at when is there a 50
chance of having a wrath there and i
graph that you see it's starting to look
like it's a bit of a straight line so
maybe
maybe a linear relationship would be the
right thing
it's sort of suggestive anyway and
actually i was a little less
scathing of the simulation approach
because at least gave some sort of idea
of what might be going on
but i had no way of proving it until um
i came to berkeley and had the fortune
of meeting with el cannon masal who had
some very nice ideas of how to look at
this problem
and
we were able to show
this result basically it is linear it's
the transition point and the result i've
put up here is certainly not the
strongest if
this delta here i could
i could replace
n to the one plus delta by n times log n
if you like or n times log log in or
whatever same here
basically if it's faster than linear the
probability of a ref goes to one if it's
slower than linear it goes to zero in
fact one can say even a little bit more
that for any given n so not a limiting
statement but for any given n
if mu is greater than lambda in
in the probability that there exists a
rap
within this binary polymer system
is at least 1 minus 2
2 e to the minus lambda to the t
t is the
size of the food set so maybe 2 over 1
minus
2 e to the minus lambda which of course
goes to 1. the nice thing about this
statement is it's not asymptotic it's
true for any given value
of n and if you work rather than over a
two letter alphabet over a k letter
alphabet
it's really easy you just change that to
k
okay so
nothing mysterious happens when you move
to more than two letters
so here's the interesting thing though
the contrast with caps these are the
ones you had to build up
automatically in this case the story is
totally different you really do need
exponential
growth rate in the expected number of
reactions catalyzed it's a two to the n
type relationship
so listen yeah listens
was was sort of right in
in a certain sense that um
if if you insist on the stronger notion
of a calf you really do need exponential
rates but if you're happy to live with
rats with things that can get started
and then become
faster
then it's definitely much slower
so we found this contrast in these rates
rather surprising perhaps you wouldn't
think too much about
there being a big difference
so more recently we've been interested
in
what happens with the sizes of refs when
they emerge in this binary polymer model
once again oh well first of all i should
say
we know that finding the biggest ref is
easy what about finding the smallest
wrap
it turns out that there's a reduction
with the problem
vertex cover that shows that this is mp
hard
given an instance of vertex cover you
can construct a catalytic reaction
system for which
the corresponding problems agree
so let's say that a ref is irreducible
if it contains no proper sub-breath in
other words if i remove any reaction
from it
there's no breath anymore in that system
so finding a new ref is easy take the
max ref
pull out a reaction
and see if there's a subgraph etc and
you if it doesn't you put that back and
try another one so it's easy in terms of
the
the polynomial and the size of the
system
but the problem is it can be
exponentially many
irreducible rafts
here is a
contrived system i've created that has
exactly eight
uh wraths
and
you by if you look closely at what
what's gone on here you could see how to
do that for
two to three
perhaps
and you might think well maybe all the
ers have the same size they do in this
example but actually that's not the case
in the binary polymer model when we
search for iraf's
they often have you know very different
sizes the big ones little ones and so
forth and we got interested in this
question well how small could they be
actually
we know it's hard to compute it
um so
oh yeah there's a interesting unsolved
problem for a computer science student
who wants to
uh find something new
anyway carrying on so
we were interested in the size of the
ers now here we've got the binary
polymer model we're increasing the
catalyzation rate and we look at where
refs first emerge this is the size of
the max ref and this is the size of the
irreducible refs that we find
when we search for them
but we don't know
because the problems wouldn't be hard
and we were just searching heuristically
we don't know that there might not be
really tiny
urefs down here
so can we use
is really where we need to use
mathematics to
try and prove a theorem
and basically we're able to show that
when
refs first appear in other words at this
linear transition point
you never get small
refs the probability that r naught
contains a ref of size less than two to
the c and c here is any constant less
than one third
this goes to zero as in increases
and that's kind of i found that
interesting because
uh
balabash
bella balabash and
rasmussen way back in 1989
also motivated by considerations of
origin of life they'd said well let's
look at
random digress imagine you have points
and you start putting cycles in sort of
randomly when will you first find a
directed cycle
sort of a slightly more primitive notion
than what we're talking about here
and what they found is that when when
directed cycles do first appear they're
of all sizes you have big ones the small
ones and so forth but for refs it's
quite different and
i think what's going on here is that the
ref couples these two concepts of f
generated and auto catalytic and it's
sort of somehow
being able to satisfy those
simultaneously you can't do it with just
a small subset
so that's just a recent result
um
but these
it has entered say here uh generally
t yeah so two to the t length yeah t is
just the length of the food molecules
okay so
so in general um the max ref of course
can have quite an interesting structure
can contain many other sub refs
here's one
wrath we found in a simulation of the
binary polymer model that breaks down
into these two parts
and in fact you can form the post-set
the partially ordered set the hassi
diagram of that
in this way so you can start to build up
these things you can compute these
efficiently
uh finding all the maximal proper
subgraphs of the max ref is it can be
done in polynomial time
you can construct this
uh the subgraphs and
there's a number of other things that
are easy to compute in polynomial time
the the reason the sub refs are
interesting i think is that
um is this idea
that
um
we're not just looking at one thing
maybe
maybe this could then co-opt we could
have these things coming together and
becoming a larger system for example
uh in early um
biochemistry so you need to it's useful
to have some
some sort of insight in how into how
refs are related to each other how they
can combine
and you also have sometimes the the
notion of a set like this that is not a
wrath but when you combine it with
another f it is again a red
so some other things that are easy to
compute
are listed here
for example deciding if an arbitrary
reaction is the difference of two
wraps is easy
i won't
dwell on this too much i just want to
so what i would like to do is just talk
about some of the recent ways in which
this has been applied
to
biological data we saw this paper that
appeared in nature last year
where a group um
i think niles layman and others at
portland and elsewhere had constructed
in the laboratory as some sort of
self-sustaining automatic water
catalytic network based on
rna
ribosomes and um we sort of
fit that into our
framework i guess you have 16 reactions
18 molecules food set of size 2 64
catalyzation pairs we form you can
verify that it forms an raf
contains many uh subrafts and they
looked at there were some they found of
interest and they looked at the dynamics
here was one of the
sub-rafts but actually even within that
sub-raf
we were
you can easily construct the post-set of
all of the subreddits and so
almost half of the subsets of this
are
are also refs
and we
one of the things that vim
wanted to do was to
sort of emulate what they had done in
their paper of studying the dynamics of
these subrafts and he he used the
gillespie album to try to
gain some more insight into the results
from this paper so
i think this was a this was quite sort
of satisfying in the sense that the
biologists
involved in that study seemed to really
appreciate that
somehow what started off as a very
abstract exercise was obvious to them
in looking at a little bit more
of the features in their data than
they'd first seen
okay my second to last slide um
i dropped pretty much entirely on this
talk of vanilla model because
you know it's easy to describe but
it's reasonable to look at um
extensions of this uh one extension
might be template based catalysis so
if you have two molecules that want to
come together maybe one of the means and
zero like this and the other starts with
then you might want the catalyst to
match this so maybe you want
this to be uh the opposite of that say
one one zero
and zero zero one maybe you need that
subsequence in your molecule to act as a
catalyst for this
or you might want
the probability that x catalyses are to
depend on for example the lengths maybe
only long molecules
are good catalysts we've also looked at
what happens if the you have a sort of
partitioned
system of molecules and we've looked at
various scenarios where the catalysis
might just be within or it might be that
every molecule here catalyzes this and
everyone here catalyzes the other and so
forth
so what do we find in all of this and
i'm going to summarize basically all of
this in really
one sentence
take a deep breath
basically what we found was
that
all of these models behave
almost the same
very close to
the vanilla model when we choose the
catalyzation rate equal to what it is on
average in each of these settings huh i
did it
okay so so it's it yeah the vanilla
model although it's a silly model
actually it emulates or predicts very um
closely what these other models will
produce in terms of the probability of
raf formation
so we've also looked at what happens
when you get away from the binary
polymer model you'll notice that
in the binary polymer model if i take
the number of reactions and divide it by
the number of molecules
i get in
okay and n played a key role in those
formulae remember we had
mu equal greater than lambda in
so for more general classes of
catalytic reaction systems
you get similar results under certain
assumptions if you replace n
by this ratio the ratio of number of
reactions to number of molecules
okay that's almost it
work on going uh with some people in
germany we're looking
further at modeling real biochemical
networks that is ones of living
primitive cells we're looking
also at the impact of inhibition so
catalysis is all very fine some molecule
makes something go faster but there's
some molecules that will inhibit
reactions and maybe the reaction can't
proceed if an inhibitor is present that
complicates the analysis a lot
even determining whether there's an raf
in this more general sense where no
reaction is inhibited by any of the
molecules present turns out to now be an
np
hard problem
the um
we also haven't really considered
dynamics here you want for example the
rate at which some
product that's used by another reaction
is produced to be high enough that
there's enough of it around for the
other reaction to proceed again you can
model that but again this turns out to
be hard
so i think that's probably me done but
i'm very happy to answer questions
so
i'm not really sure what you're trying
to explain because
what needs to be explained in chemical
evolution
is how adaptations can arise before
template replication so how certain
kinds of chemical reaction network can
be selected for as opposed to others but
what you've explained is
the spontaneous formation of
basically tar
a complex um
uh reaction network
and
so
well perhaps one thing i should say is
that
at the place where these rats form at
this linear relationship you you don't
get tar you don't get all the reactions
you you get only a you haven't explained
how you can select for a subset of the
reaction
i uh we we're starting with the set of
say the set of all reactions that were
in this case present the binary polymer
model but in general you could start
with whatever reactions were going on
then
say early earth for example how would
you get from your thing to nucleotides
so how do you get sure sure i i i
shouldn't have i'm not claiming to i'm
this is just one
small part of a very complicated story
there's all sorts of uh other things
that we don't deal with at all in this
story
i mean in a paper that i wrote with
stuart nersh we showed that
what's actually relevant is this very
rare exponential structure which is not
an raf
because that's a chemical structure that
can actually be selected for it it's
it's unlikely to form that's what makes
it important for evolution
and you can then compose
uh
separate
independent cas i think the caf is
equivalent to our cabinet core
and so there has to be some
attempt at least to explain early
evolvability
how adaptations can accumulate in
chemical evolution so why can't the raf
be selected on
they can't why not because they they
form spontaneously from the food set
there's no selectable variant some of
them have the same if you're the food
sets and two different areas with
different types of reactions one can be
selected over the other if you have two
different food sets then you can yes
no combinations you can't
well we saw that there were you know you
can have potentially exponentially many
refs with you know within the next wrap
and some of them might be
well the the
simulations that vim did using the
gillespie algorithm showed that
they he could basically predict the
results of the experiments that
uh niles layman's group did so i yeah i
don't know i mean this is a small part
of a much more complex story hasn't been
demonstrated that rafs can be selectable
demonstrated in what way um
there's no simulation which is shown you
can select for a specific area
your long sentence but ended up saying
that the
mu you needed was um
linear and n
um but if i so if i look at the template
base catalyst so
naively then i would say things that
only need a short template at each end
are way overkill because each of those
would then catalyze a lot of others
right so you actually can get away with
things that need to template where they
have to cover a substantial fraction of
the lengths of the ones there so what i
was claiming is the the probability of
reformation in such a system would be
about the same as in the vanilla model
where the where every molecule had the
same um probability of catalyzing each
reaction but
where you choose that catalyzation rate
uh according to to match so the average
catalyzation
rate was the same across both systems
but that must mean that the the template
one because this enabled template one
each molecule can template lots of other
reactions
and so you think you that you don't need
anything anything like that you can yeah
so the models look quite different but
when you look at the probability of a
ref formation they they match up
um quite well
he's factoring that in because each one
in the kind of naive template model
because each one can template lots of
reactions mu in the vanilla model be
very high
right so therefore once you
therefore the template one very easily
forms around
you see it is all explained by that
change in mu you can understand it by
that change in mu and it
no no we don't that would be something
that could be done here
so not writing about dynamics but
thinking about
equilibrium solutions still
if you take into account the amount of
each
result each reactant and product and so
on
do you get competition between different
wraps and there's some selections yeah
so so
you'll notice that you know we we throw
out a lot here we throw out you know
concentrations for example and i mean
part of the idea is somehow that that
less is more with less we can say more
but yeah i mean the
the simulations that vim has done they
have taken into account concentrations
and that's been looked at you know this
do do some refs outcompete others in the
same sense
wonderful thank you very much